- [Gary] But I'm a truebred
entrepreneur and by my
definition that means
somebody who likes losing.
Meaning I think of myself much
more as a UFC fighter than
I think of as a boxer.
I like boxing more even though
that's not a popular thing to
say but I also think that in
boxing when you get a loss,
it's like a
scarlet letter, right?
You're like finished.
In UFC, everybody has losses.
That's just part of the game.
And I associate to that
sport more as an entrepreneur.
There is no great entrepreneur
that doesn't have losses.
It's not even the cliche shit of
like you learn from your losses.
Fuck that.
It's just that it meant
that you didn't take chances.
I'm not here to be like
you learn from your losses.
I'm here like,
"Oh, you have no losses?
"You didn't take any risk."
Which means you're on defense or
you're on passive mode,
which is even scarier.
You're in the middle.
I almost wish you rather be
defense than being stuck
in the middle, so...